there's Captain America there's Iron Man
whoa look at that new guy who's that
that's my queue I got to go I fight with
Captain America and I stole his shield
and I threw it at him and the hell he's
big now I got to go it was the most
amazing thing that's ever happened so Mr
Z was like Hey unre and I just sort of
flipped in hey just a second
[Music]
coming
hey we have thin walls
here the rich and the powerful They
Don't Care About Us we have to pick up
after them we have to eat their table
scraps these alien bastards are tough
you got to use the stuff they use the
world's changing it's time we change too
so what's on to retreat what next
mission we'll call you think with a
little more mentoring could be a real
asset to the
team that's not a hug I'm just grabbing
the door for you oh all right kid good
luck out there someone is collecting
stuff from Avengers battles and building
these crazy weapons this is my chance to
prove
myself no no no no no no no no
no what if somebody had died to me
different story right cuz that's on you
I wanted you to be
better 8 years without any trouble from
those bozos up in Stark Tower man this
little bastard in red tight shows up he
thinks he can tear down everything I
built I've got a Plane full of brand new
Avengers Weaponry to load up we're going
to put him out of business we're going
to take everything they
got you're not going to stop
[Music]
me do you know him too yeah stole his
shield